Hey, good afternoon,
everybody. Uh, you are surviving AWS
reinvent and we're glad you're here. This is the last
day. Let's power through. I'm Sean O'Dell. I
lead our developer experience team
at Dynatrace, and I have
Simone who, uh, actually, go ahead and
introduce yourself, Simone. Hi, everyone, Simone
here. I'm a principal solution architect at
AWS.
Perfect. Uh, and go ahead and go to the
agenda slide if you don't mind. One thing I want to mention real
quick, this is a very loose agenda, but what we
do want to cover is a few of the announcements
that have been made this week, specifically from AWS
and Dina Trace,
3 straight days of main stage
keynote introductions and
conversations. We'll talk a little bit about how we work
together and some of the things around, uh, agents
and obviously bed.
Agent Core.
And then I want to introduce a little bit of how we at
Dina Trace add and add value
and supplement
uh what the uh Amazon
team and specifically Simone,
myself, and a few others have been working on. And
so we'll go from there and then we'll have Q&A after
the, uh, after the session,
preferably in the Dina Trace booth
just to help out here in the room. But glad to have you
here today. Perfect.
So thank you very much, Sean, for introducing
this. And yes, here we can see
a slide with the partnership between
Dyna Trace and AWS.
It's a very strong partnership. Dina Trace is one
of the very valuable partners of
AWS.
And
let's dive into the topic for today.
So, Amazon Bedrock Agent Core, how many
of you are familiar with the uh this service?
Nice, quiet. Some of you. And how many of you are
using the service today?
All right, some of you.
Perfect.
So, Bedrock Agent Core is a service
that helps you to run your Agentic workload
in production, and today with Sean, we will
talk about how you can use uh Dyna trace
to observe your agents.
All right, let's start from the challenges
when building a genetic applications.
Actually,
what we hear from customers is that
building agents for proof of concept is
very easy, how to say,
because, you know, putting together an agent
is not a big deal.
However, what is difficult is.
those agents to production.
Think about the scenario that you see on the slide here.
So you may have an agent in your department
that needs to access many
tools and potentially other agents,
maybe within your department or maybe
within your organization,
and potentially even outside of your
organization, right?
And all of this can prove very complex to
do at scale
if you need to manage all the layers, including the
infrastructure and the application layer.
And actually this is one of the reasons why
Gartner believes that by 2027,
more than 40% of the Agentic AI
projects will be canceled.
And the reason why is because moving
from POC,
where there is a lot of excitement and potential.
To production where you get to the business value
is quite challenging. So there are a lot of challenges
in that. Let's take a look at the main challenges,
and then how Bedrock Agent Core addresses
those challenges and how Dynatrace further
improves that with their observability capabilities.
All right, so, um, talking about
the, uh, the challenges. So the
first challenge is that uh when you actually
build your agents, uh, uh, you need a
dedicated, uh, uh, how to say, infrastructure
and runtime to run them on, and agents
are very different from traditional
applications. Because agents require, how
to say, dedicated infrastructure that
can run maybe for minutes,
maybe for hours.
You don't really know how long an agent will run.
You don't even know how many
parallel executions the agent will will
do. So this can be very challenging
to do with traditional infrastructure.
Also, uh, LLMs are
stateless, the LLMs behind the agent. So
when you build an agent, you need the memory capabilities,
right, for the agent to know about the session,
to know about the past interactions, and
yes, in order to do that, um,
you also need capabilities, and
this also takes time.
The third one is that agents
need to access third party tools or potential
internal tools such as think
about databases, think about Google
Drive, think about
maybe your storage system,
and in order to access those tools, the agents
need identities,
and this can also be challenging to manage
in such a setup.
The 4th point is that agents
need to discover tools and
interact with those tools.
So actually connecting to discovering
and managing all those tools at scale can also
prove very challenging.
And then the 5th point is that
these agents may need to go beyond interaction
with basic tools that I mentioned before, and
they may do more advanced things, for example,
using a browser or I don't
know, generating code and
running such code, so more advanced capabilities,
and even managing all of that can prove quite difficult.
And then last but not least,
uh, you need to be able to observe your agent,
right? So you need to know what your agent
is doing, what steps it's taking, how
it's reasoning,
where it's going well, where it's going wrong,
and you need observability for that.
And doing all of this out of, uh,
how to say, um,
reinventing the wheel on all of this can be
quite challenging,
and that's why
we have released Amazon Bedrock Agent Core,
which is a set of AWS services that
help you with those challenges.
So Bedrock Agent Corps has services in 3
categories
deploying your agents, enhancing your agent,
and monitoring your agents.
So for deploying your agents,
Bedrock Agent Corp provided two families of services,
the runtime and identity.
So the runtime is a capability that
allows you to provide your agent
code. So you simply bring the core to
Agent Core,
including the framework that you need to use and
the model that you need to use. It can be any
framework, any model
on AWS or also not on
AWS Bedrock.
And uh um Agent Core
will basically take care of running
this for you on a server less run time
that scales as needed.
And then you have agent core identity. So
think about your agent being
able to interact with the various tools.
This agent needs identities, right? It
needs an identity that the services
it interact with
will use to authenticate the agent.
And then it also needs potentially federation
with things like
CGV4,
OA, or API keys, and Bedrock
Agent Corp provide all of these as part
of the identity part.
All right, so with these new components, you have the
possibility to run your agents
at scale,
and what comes next? So you need your agents
to be able to
access various tools.
And for that, the main component is the
agent core gateway. So the agent core gateway
is basically a central MCP server
where you can see, and the agent
can see all the tools that are available for the agent
to use, and those tools are called targets.
And those targets can be APIs, can be
databases that your agent will query, can
be also external tools like a Google Drive
or Salesforce or Slack that
your agent will interact with.
And then you have agent core memory where you
have short-term memory and long-term
memory. Think about an agent
doing transactions on an e-commerce
website. So this agent
would have a shorter memory,
and this shorter memory allows the agent to remember
what products are being added to the shopping cart,
who is the user making the shopping, how many
products have been added, where to ship them
before actually placing the order.
And then you have long-term memory.
Long-term memory is basically about
the agent remembering past
interactions so that any new
shopping experience in the future, for example,
can be personalized based on the user preference
and the past interactions.
And then you may need the agent
to do more advanced things, for example,
accessing the browser,
and there we have an Agent Core browser,
which is a fully managed browser
within the agent core service that scales
to 10s or hundreds of parallel
sessions, all isolated where
your agent can interact with the web
applications. And then if you need
things like code execution,
we have the agent core code interpreter.
So the idea here is that language
models are very
effective in generating code,
but they are not necessarily the best tool in
doing deterministic things, for example, calculations.
So think about an LLM then generating
a code
for a calculator in Python, and then
this code will be executed in the
agent core code interpreter to get
a deterministic calculation of
let's say, a mathematical expression.
So this is the idea. And now you have your agent
running securely, you have your agent
announced with additional tools.
How do you ensure that this is working well?
How do you monitor it once it's operate once
it's operational?
So for that you can use uh Bedrock
Agent Core
observability, which is the capability
that allows you to monitor the status
and the performance of your agent.
So, Agent Core observability
gives you a dashboard for basic observability.
But also and most importantly for this session,
it exposes a number of
let's say matrix,
logs,
spans, traces, and
sessions
that Dyna Trace would then use to do the
more advanced observability via their platform.
And now Sean will talk about this part.
So in, in, in the case of, of what we
are
expanding upon, and what I actually appreciate
from an AWS perspective is I've
been in the observability space for about 8 or 9 years
now. And when, when we
look at each of these new technologies, the,
the really the challenge has always been.
As a developer, as a consumer,
as a, as an end-user practitioner, is,
how do I get the information out of it?
Now, DynaTrace, obviously focusing on
end to end observability,
we have a care and a concern
of that exact problem or challenge,
depending on how you look at it.
And, and the way AWS is built, both
Agent core.
Uh, and specifically some of the other things around,
uh, the other announcement this week for the DevOps
agent specifically
is giving the power to you as the
end user, as the developer of
where you want to get the information from.
Obviously, CloudWatch, fantastic.
I'm a big fan of it. If you need to expand
this beyond CloudWatch, obviously, uh, I
believe in uh Simone's slide it mentioned
open telemetry, specifically those logs,
those traces, metrics.
We as at Dynatrace believe you can
bring those in beyond just
the scope of Bedrock Agent Core.
And we do this in a couple of ways. I personally
focus in and around AI observability
and specifically, yes, based upon my title,
the Developer Experience. So in my world,
it's not about dashboards,
it's not about The power of a dashboard,
it's let me start in my IDE.
Let me get the information when and where I want
to, but at the end of the day
we all know we have to see the data, and I think that's
where I love about CloudWatch.
Obviously seeing the Cloud Watch specific data
for Agent Corp plus DynaTrace.
So when we look at this a little bit further, there
are some challenges.
While, while you and I probably care
about, uh, you know, uh, Agent Core, Bedrock
Agent Corre specifically,
we realize that our enterprises, our
organizations leverage far more than just
this new
technology and or application.
So at DynaTrace, our goal is to
really take that and abstract or
not abstract it, but provide value
to. it. And so in this slide,
our idea is, hey, we've got cloud native
digital services, we've got,
you know, AI agents,
we all need to communicate together. I was having
a conversation earlier this morning, and
we still have applications that are
sitting on mainframes, etc. so
on. And so what we want to make sure is you have
visibility to all of this.
Depending on your use case and scenario,
you might say, I only care about
an agent that sits in my IDE and I'm
never going anywhere else. Perfect.
I believe Simona and the AWS team have built a fantastic
way to do that. If you need to go beyond that,
that's where we sit. That's our goal for
end to end observability.
I want to mention two things,
and, and I think this is an interesting
slide or an interesting statistic
is that 95% of AI
pilots
are failing. Now, I don't know if I
actually agree holistically just based upon
the conversation.
Maybe it's a little bit.
Loose or maybe it's historical data,
but the intelligence that Agent Core
provides, I actually believe lends to
a better success.
But along with that information is leveraging
an open source solution like open open
telemetry
allows for the consumption of that information.
The catch here is because we're talking about um
experimental or development. This
is not a day 2 conversation. This is
a day 0
conversation. And where we at Dyna Trace believe
and obviously in AWS believe is
those numbers are gonna continue to improve
from a failure rate. The second thing I would
mention here,
as a developer, and this is where I, I,
I, you know, I focus,
I'm not looking for complexity.
I don't wanna have to go from this screen to this
screen or from this IDE
to another option.
I, I want it to be where I am and
we at Diana Trace believe we wanna meet you
at that location. So whether it's your IDE,
obviously we had the announcement yesterday, um,
in conjunction with AWS around Quiro,
the, the idea is to, to meet you
in that specific uh
location. The other thing about this is
many organizations, uh, and probably
all of you in this room
are leveraging more than simply
Bedrock Agent Core.
You're testing multiple LLMs, you're testing,
um, small language models. You have a
variety of consumption.
And so what we want to uh help you
understand is not only
Bedrock Age at core,
but we also realize you have all of these others.
And so whether it's some of the third parties,
uh, Nvidia is a specific is another
great example. Our goal is
to meet you at DynaTrace, where
you are.
And so from an observability perspective, yes,
I have two different agentic applications.
Maybe one is Amazon, maybe the other one's, you
know, leveraging in video technology or anthropic
or OpenAI or one of the many vendors
on the floors today
is we want you to be able to have visibility
and understanding of both of those.
And so at Dina Trace, our goal is
just to continue to meet you where
you are. We're doing this in two different ways.
Obviously open telemetry, as I mentioned.
And open LL imagery,
and I always have a funny way I say this, but I'm going to
be nice and, and, and put it in the proper
term today.
So this is where we
believe observability goes beyond just agent
core. And so just depending on where you are
and where you need to be met.
The last The thing I wanted to show is a very simple
screen. Um, I am
sitting here in, uh, you know, a very
simple to understand and as you can tell,
this is, this happens to be the DynaTrace dashboard.
What I want to articulate here is I've got
a couple of tasks. I've got some chats, I've got some mention
and information,
and at the end of the day, hey, this is a lane graph
workflow. I see that, I see
the relative and appropriate observability
information in this example, followed by, hey,
what are some of the details, some of the metadata and the
attributes, etc.
This is a visual representation,
right? I love to sit in my ID
using natural language search.
I want to be able to do this from my IDE
and obviously the integration with an MCP
from an AWS perspective, from a Dynatrace
perspective is now I can get it in a GUI,
but I can also get it inside of my
preferred location, right? Whether it's Quiro,
whether it's, uh, you know, VS code
or Windsurf or depending on what you're using.
And so that is our goal to meet
you, not only from an agent core agent
perspective,
but the variety of LLMs
and observability or excuse me, the LLMs,
um, small language models and
AI capabilities, right?
In every one of our organizations, the other
side of this is,
what if I'm leveraging another solution.
like a Service now or a,
uh, you know, it could be a
variety of the ecosystem. Our
goal is to provide you the information
from an observability perspective, not only for
Agent Core, but beyond in the
same fashion that's usable and
predictable for you. And we, and
as developers and engineers
love some decent predictability, at least I
hope you do. Uh, the last thing I would mention
at Dyna Trace,
just to summarize this.
We're about experience. I was having a
conversation last night, you know, one of the things that that
we, we struggle with in the industry
is complexity.
As a developer, as an engineer,
I want to reduce complexity. I want to be back in
the flow. I want to,
I realize I have to troubleshoot. I have to
debug because things are going to happen.
But the quickest way for me to get in
and out of a debug mode,
troubleshooting mode.
is to do it in a quick instant in, in,
in really
simple to easy to use fashion. And so one
of the things we've continued to build upon
as the agent core team and as the, as the
Bedrock team has developed this, is to
ensure usability or experience.
And so whether that's developer experience and beyond.
I think the last piece I would mention before we
close it out
is all of this runs on
infrastructure.
Now as a developer, do I love to
interact with infrastructure? Probably
not. Maybe I have to, but
it's all been abstracted to me. But
from an observability perspective, I care,
and I, it's a concern to me. And what
we realize is from an end to end observability
perspective, it's not just the LL.
or the AI observability. It's not just
the logs, traces and metrics.
It's the relative infrastructure
information and relative infrastructure data
in context.
And so having each of these layers,
right, depending on your scenario, depending on the
use case, depending on the problem,
we want to meet you where you are.
And every job, every developer I talked to about
this, in some cases, it's, I
need to start with logs.
Or I need to start with a metric
or a span. For the record, there is no
single point that I have ever found in
this. It really depends on the day, it
depends on the scenario, and in the
situation. And so we want to do is make it readily
available and easy to you.
Because it would never be the AWS infrastructure
and it would never be the network, right?
But we want to make sure you start where you
need to be and that's how we, we position
this as the data trace difference.
Lastly, I will say this, come meet us at the booth.
The team has got about 2 more hours, well. I
got about an hour and a half now to go,
but we have a, a free giveaway at a raffle
here in about 10 minutes. So if you want to run
by there, have a conversation with myself,
have a conversation with Simone,
or join the raffle and win some things, we
would love to have you. But I would say this last and
not least.
It has been a long week.
We at Dina Trace and at Data Buss realize
it's been long.
You've been in a lot of meetings. You've been in a lot of
sessions, but I wanna say thank you for stopping
by towards the end of the day.
Come find us, come find me, come find Simone.
We'd love to talk with you, and we hope you have a great
trip home, and we'll see you again next year.